[Music]
the race to find alternatives to russian
energy has accelerated after moscow's
decision to cut its supply of natural
gas to bulgaria and poland is another
very stark reminder that we need to work
with reliable partners and build our
energy independence
the european union gets around 40
percent of its gas from russia
but as the war in ukraine rages on the
block said it aims to slash two-thirds
of its purchases by the end of the year
to help cover this shortfall the u.s has
ramped up shipments of liquefied natural
gas or lng to its western allies but
this move has also begun to drain
domestic supplies and is pushing up
prices in the u.s
we're pretty much tapped out um there's
there's nothing more
to send
here's why providing natural gas from
the u.s is so complicated and what
energy producers are trying to do about
it
even before russia invaded ukraine
domestic inventories of natural gas
across the us were already lean due to
various factors
there have been extreme weather events
like a cold snap in texas that paralyzed
power plants and helped drain global
stockpiles
plus during the pandemic u.s producers
tapped into their inventory of already
drilled wells amassed over years instead
of drilling new costly wells draining
their inventory kept them afloat
financially but has limited their
ability to grow production now that
fossil fuel demand is growing
then came russia's invasion of ukraine
and heightened calls on the eu to reduce
its reliance on russian energy and to
help with that transition president
biden made a pledge we're taking
additional steps in lockstep with our
allies and partners to raise the
economic pressure on putin these steps
come at a time when the amount of gas in
storage in the lower 48 states is 17
below the five-year average for this
time of year
despite dwindling supply the u.s now
aims to send 50 billion cubic meters of
lng to europe every year until at least
2030. that would make up for about a
third of the gas the eu receives from
russia
since the war that the u.s has become
the largest supplier of liquefied
natural gas to europe but there's a
limit to how much the u.s can supply
and for american producers looking to
supply more lng overseas it's no easy
feat that's because transporting natural
gas is more complicated than oil or coal
after the gas is drilled from the ground
it's put through a pipeline it's then
sent to a plant that functions like a
massive refrigerator where it's chilled
into a liquid state for shipping
that super refrigerator that turns it
into a liquid those are multi-billion
dollar facilities the ones that are
running that we have built right now are
running at full capacity and building
these super refrigerators could take
years really the earliest that
additional
u.s supplies could be put on the market
to europe or anywhere
is
20 25 2026. the federal energy
regulatory commission has given the
green light to build 13 new lng
facilities in the u.s but companies
haven't started construction largely
because many haven't been able to secure
the financing and some producers are
worried about whether there'll be a
demand for lng in the long run amid a
global transition to cleaner energy
what they need is
commercial certainty that
there's demand for this product and and
not just demand now but demand over the
long term so usually these projects are
seeking
20-year supply deals because it can take
as much as seven years to even begin
seeing a return
but in the short term as these options
are debated consumers will feel the
pinch we are now the largest exporter of
natural gas in the world so
there's just more demand
for the gas coming out of the u.s and
that's going to push prices higher for
the foreseeable future